some of the worst
guys to date in the country
are in new york city everybody will tell
you that you will hear women all the
time from the northeast saying you got
to get out of new york you got to get
even go to new jersey just do something
to get out they are the worst guys to
date i'll tell you why
first of all they're not gentlemanly
at all
they're not they're not gonna open your
car door
they're gonna look to split the bill i'm
telling you straight
okay they're not gonna come drop you off
pick you up at the front door none of
that stuff i mean maybe they'll hell a
cab for you you're gonna pay for it
honey
nine out of ten times you're gonna pay
for it they'll open that door maybe hail
that cat and be like ah see you later ah
yep you know what you're not gonna get a
call either making sure you got in okay
at the other end you're not gonna get a
call believe me i have a ton of single
friends right now in new york city
you're not gonna get that call maybe
you'll get a text
the next day
okay maybe